joining me now mark levin the great one
host of life
liberty and levin and the author of the
fantastic new book
american marxism mark thank you so much
congrats on the new book
but i got to say you also literally
wrote the book on americanism i remember
when i read it rediscovering americanism
americanism is the opposite of globalism
how are we to stop what i'm dubbing
global joe's agenda
well you start by having a brilliant
monologue like yours so we actually talk
about the facts
and we actually take our language back
and call things what they actually are
you know the purpose of immigration
is not to support the country from which
the immigrant comes from or even the
immigrant the purpose of immigration has
historically been what's in the best
interests of the american people
but when you believe the american people
are systemically racist
you don't really care what's in the best
interests of the american people
the democrat party does not love this
country a matter of fact as each day
goes by demonstrates that it hates this
country
so does the president of the united
states you listen to that
state of confusion speech it was
abundantly clear he never talked about
liberty he never talked about personal
responsibility he never talked about
unalienable rights he never talked about
property rights he never talked about
the things upon which this nation
was based joe biden of the democrat
party want to fundamentally change
america
if you want to fundamentally change
something you don't like it as a matter
of fact
you hate it massive taxation massive
regulation
massive spending massive debt they're
igniting inflation as we speak
wide open southern border you have ms-13
drugs pouring across the border
you have massive child abuse going on
there and joe biden doesn't give a damn
they pick the teachers union and the
muscle that union over educating our
children
they're undermining our police they're
undermining our military
they're pushing racism in our schools so
people are constantly at each other's
throats
they are strengthening the regime in
iran which threatens to shoot nuclear
missiles at us once they acquire them
he's cow tung to the communist chinese
he aims to destroy the supreme court
pact the senate eviscerate the election
laws
does this sound like a man and a party
that love this country i don't think so
on this immigration front assimilation a
country
simply cannot survive if its culture
if its principles are not shared by the
citizens yes
a country simply cannot survive if our
elementary school students and middle
school students and high school students
are being taught racism packaged as
something else
our colleges and universities are
hotbeds of old soviet
propaganda now we have to claw our way
back but
it begins first by identifying exactly
what's going on
this isn't democratic socialism this
isn't liberalism
this isn't progressivism this is an
american form of marxism where you have
oppressors and oppressed
where you have class warfare taking
place here
joe biden has no intention of bringing
this country together and i want to tell
you why pete
joe biden has never ever been anything
but a two-bit street politician at a
wilmington delaware
he's never done anything in the private
sector his entire life
he lied his way through law school he
lied his way throughout his senate
career
he lied his way in a few presidential
campaigns and he was caught
back then it actually mattered when he
was mouthing words that robert kennedy
and neil cunnick the head of the labor
party in britain said
today it doesn't much matter we have a
man in the oval office
who wants to be fdr who wants to be lbj
and he wants to be barack obama
he doesn't want to be a great patriot at
a time of great threats to the united
states not even close and he is creating
he is creating a domestic situation here
where he is at war with the economy he's
a war with our immigration system
he's at war with the middle class he's
cow towing to our enemies
i mean uh i don't think we've ever seen
anything like this in modern american
history i think for so many people
watching it
the the the speed with which the
trajectory of this country
changed from donald trump to whoever's
running joe biden
uh it's got people beside themselves
there was just an announcement tonight
uh that that president donald trump
former president now has a social media
platform that he'll use more frequently
to share videos and information
what should he be saying what do
patriots need to be saying to fight back
against american marxism how do you
defeat this
first of all i feel like we are the
salsa nations here
and i feel like donald trump is a
tremendous patriot who's
trying to find ways to crack through
this autocracy that is growing
and growing at speeds that we never
thought before first of all kudos to the
president that is president trump
for doing this i think these uh these
big tech companies they have used dark
money and other things to influence our
elections
they're the biggest threat we have to
free speech and freedom of association
in this country
i think the big media in this country is
in the bag for the democrats
it's no different than the media for
putin or g or the rest
they are utterly and completely corrupt
which is a grave threat to this country
i think what we need to do quite frankly
is we need to take many of the tactics
of the left whether it's
a clown and pivon whether it's a linsky
whether it's the bds movement and apply
it to them and that's one of the things
i talk about
in the book and we need to use their
tactics against them because they've
been
so effective i look at a guy like james
o'keefe for example whose
motto of project veritas is be brave do
something
you have to do something to expose it
otherwise they control everything
and your books mark i gotta say we're
out of time but your books
from rediscovering americanism to
american marxism
have charted the course for a generation
of constitutional conservatives
and we're so grateful for you thank you
for the fight and for for lighting the
way for us we appreciate it mark
pete thanks for your patriotism both on
and off the battlefield god bless you my
friend mark thank you so much and thanks
for joining us on fox news primetime we
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else